welcome to this special episode of firm
learning
if you wish this is firm learning
breaking news
because i trust that many of you might
already have seen the document
from a set of first year goldman sachs
analysts
there was now published that was leaked
and is currently making it around the
internet
so lots of major news publications have
already talked about it so in this video
i want to do the following thing
we will now jointly look into this
document from these
first year goldman sachs analysts and i
will reflect on that based on my
experience as a former mckinsey
consultant and i will also contrast that
of how this compares
to working in a tier one consulting firm
to working in an mbb consulting firm so
like mckinsey bcg or bain
or anything of the like so let's dig
into it so to get to this deck i just
googled goldman sachs
working conditions survey and then
somewhere here
it appears so this is the document that
everybody is now indeed talking about so
let's
have a look so what does it say working
condition survey from goldman sachs
february 2021 so apparently also just to
be very clear here
apparently this is not officially been
released by goldman but rather was
created by a set of analysts
that they then used and apparently then
also distributed to the media i don't
know the details of this
but where they then talk about the
working conditions
at that firm and here of course
it really gets juicy right so it says on
average first year analysts are working
over
95 hours per week and sleeping
five hours per night and specifically
when they were asked about how much they
worked in the last week
they said that they worked 105 hours
and this is just crazy because indeed if
you do the calculation
this really means that these people
pretty much work every
saturday every sunday and from my
friends who work in these very large
banks in frankfurt or london
i know that this is actually the case
right so it's really expected in many of
these firms
again don't want to say anything about
the specifics on goldman sachs but just
in general what i have heard from people
working there
apparently these people really are
expected to come into the office every
saturday
and every sunday and if you are a
regular watcher of my channel you might
have already seen this video that i
did on the regular work week of a
consultant i will insert it somewhere
above here
but if you have seen that you know that
actually this is usually not
expected from you in consulting so based
on my
former employer i know that there was a
very strong
culture of not working at all on the
weekend on saturday on sunday
of course then this also relates to
sleep and then at the time where you go
to sleep and apparently here this was 3
a.m
so they say that they sleep 5 hours per
night so i had some weeks in consulting
where really the workload was
quite high and i also only 3 a.m where i
went to bed and
also a couple of weeks were really only
slept five hours on average in that week
so this happened occasionally but this
was for sure
not the average this was really the
absolute spike the absolute outlier
the baseline was much less than that
than what is shown here
okay next near-term retention
so the question is you're always if
conditions stay the same what is the
likelihood you stay
with the firm in one month in three
months
and in six months from one to ten ten is
high one is low
and of course here you can see that
based on that the the likelihood that
they will still be at the firm in six
months
is not that high though i would argue
that this is
given the conditions that are described
still a rather high value right so
apparently
this firm does seem to offer something
to these people
that at least in some extent might seem
it maybe not bearable but
somehow compensate for what they're
experiencing right but for sure
this is not looking good your next one
effect on physical and mental health
so how does your mental health
change before and after the job and here
as well what is the development of your
physical health
before and after the job and both of
them this is what you see here always
rated from one to ten
ten is the best with a significant
decrease
so for sure balancing working in
consulting with
sports with a healthy lifestyle can be
challenging but if you really make this
a priority it is possible
and personally i made it always a
priority of trying to do at least
one time sport during the week during
the work week i even
tried to do it twice every work week so
it didn't
happen every single time it didn't work
out every single time but i made it
happen quite frequently
so next what else are they saying so the
question
how have your work hours negatively
impacted relationships with family and
friends they all said yes
there was some negative impact in here i
must say
probably also in consulting it's really
difficult to say that working consulting
will not have any negative effect on
your relationships with family and
friends
because of course the truth is that in
consulting your normal work week
is just that from monday to thursday you
are not at home
but you're working client side and then
of course if you don't see your family
and friends the whole week
this is difficult and especially if you
have a family this that usually means
that they're not seeing your children
from monday to thursday
this can really be tough and here maybe
the bankers even have the advantage
because even though they come home late
at least they come home every night
though probably it's not that much of a
use if you really
only sleep at 3 a.m and i need to get
out in the morning again right but here
i'd say
consulting isn't much better honestly
the next do you feel
you've been a victim of workplace abuse
and here a big big majority says
yes and here i must say this is for sure
not
the atmosphere that i've experienced in
consulting so in consulting
people are really focusing a lot on
treating everybody professionally
on treating everybody with respect so as
always there are also always outliers
here as well and for sure you will
always have some examples of people
who cannot behave themselves or whatever
but for sure this is not
systemic to the environment in
consulting i'd rather argue
exactly the opposite way around based on
my experiences
i've seen everybody treated with highest
levels of respect
so have you frequently experienced
unrealistic deadlines
shunned ignored in meetings unwarranted
invalid
or public criticism and here especially
for the first two
a lot of years here for banking so
unrealistic deadlines
i mean unrealistic is of course a
relative fear right but tough deadlines
for sure
is what you will face in consulting as
well so here i'd argue probably very
similar
and also unwarranted invalid or public
criticism
of course this is always very relative
as well and subjective right so
probably very rarely somebody gets very
very tough criticism and we say yes this
was 100
absolutely justified i mean of course
there are these instances but this we're
not the norm
so it's a bit difficult but for sure
where i'd say it's different in
consulting is that you are
shunned and ignored in meetings this is
not what i've seen my experience is that
really from day one from being a first
week young junior analyst in consulting
you will be encouraged to sit in client
meetings not only sit in client meetings
but
actively participate and very quickly
also need these meetings
so this is i'd say a big difference you
will be really
be thrown in the water very very quickly
and we just expected
to just run in these meetings to lead
them to guide them to have these client
interactions
so this apparently does seem to be
different here he just goes on and on
blaming without justification
shouting or swearing excessive
monitoring or micromanagement
you just want to emphasize my point
especially on the shouting or swearing
again there are always outliers but this
for sure is not the norm in consulting
and here also to be fair also you're
only a minority seems to regularly
experience
these things in banking so other things
how satisfied are you with your firm
work life personal life no surprise that
apparently people aren't that satisfied
now if you were to move on to another
role
how likely would you recommend goldman
sachs you still quite high interestingly
enough
and yeah i guess you can read i don't
find this this interesting
and now one slide that is just crazy i
mean oh
wow this is this is so bad i mean just
just read this i don't even want to read
all this out but just the first one
the sleep deprivation the treatment by
senior bankers
the mental and physical stress i've been
through
foster care and this is arguably worse
ah this is bad this is
really bad i mean then the other ones as
well my body physically hurts all the
time and mentally i'm in a really dark
place
i didn't come into this job expecting a
9 am to 5 pm
but i also didn't expect consistent
9 am to 5 a.m either
and here you can just you know read the
rest for yourself
this is just crazy and again i
i trust that now you can already sense
this from what i've said earlier
but this is not what the reality in
consulting looks like
again i by no means want to glorify
working in consulting it can be really
tough and challenging as well but not
like this i promise you
maybe there are some peaks a week or
maybe also two or three weeks which can
be really really tough
depending on the types of projects that
you do but this for sure
will not be the baseline and even on the
toughest weeks
you will not consistently work from 9am
to 5am this is
what i've never seen happen only once on
any of the projects that i worked at
this is just what i can say
and in the end also interestingly enough
they have some
suggestions on what to do to rectify the
situation
and here is when i don't want to go too
much into the detail but just here the
first one so 80 hours per week should be
considered
max capacity so their demand is to work
80 hours per week and again just to
contrast this with consulting
i'd argue that probably the average in
consulting is around
60 to 65 hours per week and with ups and
downs there will be weeks where you will
also work
more than 80 hours but for sure this is
not the baseline
so it is fair to say that apparently
working in investment banking seems to
be a bit tougher at least at this
specific firm if this is true
then working in consulting of course now
you could also argue that
of course your salary will be a bit
higher and banking especially also in
the long term will be more high it will
be higher in banking than in consulting
and yeah if you just want to read the
rest feel free
so this just some reflections on my end
i'd be super happy to hear from you in
the comments
are you working in banking consulting
does this resonate does this make sense
maybe even some some insiders from gs or
some other firms
let us know what it's really like
whether this is really the case
and if you've never watched this channel
before my name is heinrich
from learning i'm a former mckinsey
consultant usually on my channel i talk
about how to be successful
in the first years of your career i
share tips on slide writing creating
presentations
how to behave in meetings how to
structure your work
so all these things that i learned
during my past work experience
where i try to help you with your work
life as well
so looking forward usually i release
videos every single saturday this was
not a bonus video
so looking forward to that cheers this
is honey from from learning bye bye